this is their new home they have nothing
here but at least they're alive there
are tens of thousands of unregistered
Inga's and makeshift refugee camps like
this one here in Bangladesh many have
been here for years but right now there
are countless new arrivals every day
they're coming across the border from
Myanmar which is just a few miles away
from here they're fleeing from violence
back home and the stories they have to
tell are gruesome so beer cartoon and
some of her family are among those who
made it they say their village was
raided by Myanmar security forces four
family members didn't manage to escape
their assailants do normally do they
were shooting at us indiscriminately
they abused our women they dragged us
out of our homes like a bunch of animals
three of my sons are still missing and
I'm really worried about them one of my
daughters with six children has lost her
husband she was raped to be his daughter
can't forget the voices of the attackers
telling us get out get out of here this
is not your country they told us if you
stay you'll be killed
exterminated like insects those who
resisted was stabbed and they were left
there just to die slow death some of
them were abused they ripped out her
earrings and our nose pants bleeding
Delaney loves you hold on I'll cool it
okay I got you do i we are still alive
but this is not living my sons were shot
I left them behind I don't know what
happened to them oh my god where should
I go now the women have been raped the
children have been killed they've been
left behind without proper burial my god
why have you kept me alive to see all
this it's difficult to independently
verify these claims because for weeks
the Myanmar government didn't let anyone
into the affected areas but no matter
who you ask here you always hear the
same stories of torture rape and death
abdullah enough to is uncertain about
the fate of some of his family members
he said several were caught while they
were on the run we were hiding in paddy
fields in the underbrush and in the
jungle we ran for the river to cross the
border to the other side but we couldn't
cross right away we waited there for a
week without food or anything
most of the new arrivals have made it
into Bangladesh with nothing more than
the shirts on their backs here they are
safe but only a few want to stay if the
situation improves they say they would
go back but they know full well that
that day may never come